did you have any other damage to
any of your other organs because i know
that the liver itself is quite robust
it it's it's it's like one of the organs
that you can do a ton of damage to doing
and you can really bring it back from
what i've heard you know reasonably
easily you know kidneys are a different
story but did you have any other damage
to any of the other
organs no yeah just the liver and it's
purely from the high food intake and
never really taking a break and always
being a little bit higher than
true hormone replacement um so the liver
had non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
which now with ultrasounds and fibro
scans and and doing my blood work
frequently that's now completely
resolved
no issues with my kidneys normal
globular filtration rate normal cystitis
and sea levels all my blood work is good
i've done ultrasounds of my kidneys
normal no inflammation no
kidney stones no nothing i've done an
mri on my heart
normal size surprisingly because i i
would expect a little bit of an
athlete's heart
but i've been so proactive to prevent
that that
my heart is a normal size with normal
injection fraction and and
no coronary artery disease no plaque
buildup so whatever you use to maintain
your
heart health and size so it doesn't get
enlarged like like are we talking things
like uh
coenzyme q10 uh ubiquinol
ubiquinol so i take 200 milligrams per
day
it's pretty high dose and then i take it
also around the workout
which gives a little bit of a
performance performance enhancing
benefits because
you're supplying energy and antioxidants
to the heart allowing it to work at full
capacity
and when you train for bodybuilding of
course the training intensity is quite
high right
so your heart isn't under a lot of
stress and while you're giving
all your audio body parts a break and
you turn legs one day and then back the
next day and chest the next day
but your heart five times a week is
getting hammered
so i put everything in place to ensure
heart health which is
400 milligrams would be known on
training days sometimes 500 milligrams
and i started taking a bit of blocker to
keep the heart rate down
so you always right you're not in this
sympathetic state where you're always
like a little bit hyped up after
training what's up
like is that a is that something that
you need to get scripted from your
doctor is that something you get over
the counter as far as a beta blocker
because i mean like one of the things
i've noticed because i wear this aura
ring to track my sleep and my heart rate
all that sort of stuff
is my average heart rate is a little bit
higher than
what i think it should be like it's
around i mean on low days it might be in
low 50s but it's usually 59 to 63 like
even when i'm asleep
okay yeah yeah you can get that down
yeah yeah so a bit of blocker it depends
on the country
um so here i can buy it over the counter
it's one of the good things about
thailand i can get 99
of what i want over the counter
um but no script maybe you just go to
the pharmacy or the chemist
no just go to the pharmacy you walk in
he said i need nebulitt
which is uh nabivolol you know the
pharmaceutical brand
and they they'll give it to you you know
as long as you pay for it it's all right
i have to convince my doctor to script
it and they're always touching
everything right so and that's why
there's online pharmacies but then
you're running the risk of importation
there's always a risk of prescribing
stuff online um
self-prescribing stuff online but it's
basically the bodybuilding scene anyway
i mean you're self-prescribing
because we're taking more than hormone
replacement so you get quite resourceful
figuring out where to get stuff um
besides what you're able to get on
prescription and if you need a
prescription well there's always methods
to
negotiate with your doctor you get it
prescribed right because
maybe let there's no underground labs or
a nabival there's no underground labs
that produce that stuff so you have to
get pharmaceutical grade
well i'll i'll tell you a story in a
minute though like you know literally
made my trt doctor jump out of his chair
when i had to go through some labs but
um i'm just gonna try to catch these
super chats as they come in uh so did
you know matt says
what do you wish you knew about tess
when you were young that you know that
you know now i guess is the
full question um all esters are the same
if you do your
uh injection frequency more frequently
so i just started again a cycle after
being off for about eight and a half
months
and other side um man acne is coming
back already
so that's because of hormonal
fluctuations so even though if you
take a longer testosterone ester twice a
week
if you inject that every day you get
more stable serum concentrations
and one of the issues with taking
steroids
is these hormonal fluctuations causing
too much conversion into estrogen
which then you have high test and then
high estrogen and then high test and
high estrogen
and this fluctuations contributes to
acne or gynecomastia or water retention
or maybe hair loss because the
testosterone converts into
dihydrotestosterone
which is one of the uh causes for hair
loss now i think for you that's
really not an issue um and for me
neither
it is because you chose to be right
shaven
and i seem to be immune for hair loss
but everybody gets some sort of side
effect
whether that's acne or hair loss or
gynecomastia or water retention
those are like the the low hanging fruit
side effects
that are almost immediate and what i
wish i knew
is that regardless of the testosterone
formula that you're taking if you
administer that
every day you mitigate a lot of these
side effects
one of the questions i i get a lot from
guys
like on t is essentially well
aren't you going to lose your hair and i
mean the way that i handle it i'd love
to hear your feedback
way that'll handle it is if you're
predisposed like if you were
already losing your hair before you
added therapeutic doses of testosterone
you're you're probably going to continue
to lose your hair or it may accelerate
but if you've never been really losing
much of your hair
pre-trt it's it's probably not going to
do anything right
yeah generic predisposition highly
contributes so you have a
condition called androgenetic alopecia
which is basically
the same as benign prostate enlargement
and then it's it's
mostly hereditary it's how your body
responds to dihydrotestosterone dht yeah
yeah and it also depends on how much
dihydrotestosterone you're producing
so funnily enough i produce a ton of
dihydrotestosterone
my testosterone is in the middle of the
range and my
my dihydrotestosterone is two and a half
times out of the reference
range yet i have no hair loss
it's not in my family and i have no
prostate enlargement which is confirmed
with ultrasounds multiple times
so it really depends on how much you're
converting and how
predispositioned you are to the response
of that now if you're
right if your response if your response
is severe then all the
dihydrotestosterone derivatives are off
the table the primobolan the anova the
winstrol the
astron etc um so
right all you have to do is look it to
your parents on grandparents
if you're bald you're going to get bald
and you have to put some preventative
measures in place to prevent that from
happening and there's
well a million different methods which
i'm not familiar with
because i didn't have to i never had to
deal with the hair loss
that's why we have uh you know derek for
more placement dates she's highly
specialized
yeah i was gonna say hair loss
prevention yeah if you want to learn how
to keep your hair um
you know watch this channel because he's
got tons of videos
on strategies to try to hold i'm of the
just shave your head club um
yeah i've i've used um you know prima
ballin on
on top of trt i've used um you know like
anavar on top of trt and those are the
ones that he's talking about that
convert that
can be problematic if you're predisposed
to hair loss i wanted to ask you about
the enlarged prostate thing because
um i i've heard conflicting stories on
it i've heard dht
is a contributor to enlarged prostate
issues and i've seen other
uh doctors and even guys on youtube i
think dr eric berg is one of the
more prominent ones with a large channel
um say things like
uh i think it was estrogen and insulin
are the causes of
enlarged prostate what's your take on
that it's it's one of those organs
that's
uh responds to a lot of different things
including stress
like what i saw in the when i was still
consulting and you're
surrounded with consultants around 50
years old and they're in a high stress
environment 24 7.
they get all sorts of issues hair loss
prostate enlargement
um all kinds of issues when you say
stress like like like stress measured as
cortisol levels in the blood yeah
well one of those and of course stress
is also something
self-induced how you respond to
particular situations now nubile helps
with that because it keeps your
sympathetic nervous system
down a little bit and your heart rate
down as well so you're able to be a
little bit more uh
stress resistant that way that's one of
the also
hidden reasons why i take an avival
right because being self-employed is
also
a little bit of a stressful environment
because there's so much influx of work
now for the guys that are in a high
stress environment that could have a
compounding effect on prostate
enlargement
same as the dihydrotestosterone same as
um
there's a condition called varicose
cells which is the impaired blood flow
to the testicles
whether that's from testosterone therapy
or
just pure circulation or having the area
too hot
that can also cascade into prostate
enlargement so there's
a lot of new evidence coming out of why
prostate enlargement
occurs and right from the steroid world
the problem is the guys that are running
uh very high doses of steroids are never
really honest about what's going on in
their body
because they don't want to they don't
want to say that they're having a
complication later on in life
so we see some clinical evidence that uh
dihydrotestosterone and steroids cause
some prostate enlargement
but personally i haven't seen that
really to happen
but right the the clinical literature
say that benign prostate enlargement
occurs
slowly over time due to dehydrator
testosterone
um so maybe you don't have it at the age
of 30 but by the age of 50 you might
have it
do do males make more dht
in their body as they get older because
i mean one of the things that
um i've heard is that um like
it's a normal process for your prostate
to enlarge as you get older as a male
so don't worry about it too much unless
it turns into something problematic like
cancer or
your psa markers you know spike and
there's other things to look at
um so is it so is it your body making
more dht as you get older
no it's a community effect over time
which
makes it a little bit tricky because if
you're a bodybuilder or you're doing trt
plus and you take a dihydrotestosterone
derivative that then compounds
on top of the dihydrotestosterone that
you're producing naturally or
converting from the testosterone so now
let's say you're drug free until the age
of 25 you have
a certain burden of dht on your prostate
and then you go on primo now five times
higher than
your natural dht levels this is
compounding into benign prostate
enlargement which might accelerate it
over time
and i haven't seen it in my immediate
surroundings and i'm in touch with a lot
of bodybuilders who take
a lot of a lot of dihydrotestosterone
derivatives
so i think it's it's just a compiling
effect same as with acne
and and and gynecomastia all these organ
issues it's usually
multifactorial and the best we can do is
just
monitor it with organ imaging and blood
work
and then make the appropriate actions
but i've seen more benign plastic
enlargement with guys who are not
using steroids who are in high stress
environments and don't really take care
of their health
smoking drinking uh you know to take the
edge off of work
and those guys usually get far worse uh
organ issues than the guys that
use steroids and take care of their
health a low stress environment and
exercise frequently so right all these
things you just have to keep track of
and
some guys get unlucky i did their
response is far worse than general
population and their
their organs are not agreeing the same
is with me with the non-alcoholic fatty
liver disease
because i know people who did far worse
right food-wise steroid-wise and
and didn't have any issues with their
liver what's the um
like what was the signal that you know
caused concern with the fatty liver
disease like was it a distended abdomen
like was it blood work
how did you didn't catch it i didn't
catch it as much as i know
um about organ health i did not catch it
because
the symptoms of non-alcoholic fatty
liver disease are not that apparent
when you're a bodybuilder um so i did
not have high triglycerides in the
bloodstream i did not
i had a little bit of issue getting
leaner but as the body were like okay
i'm
getting a little bit older my metabolism
is coming down
um like if you have fat in the liver it
makes it difficult to
lose body fat that's one of the side
effects immediate side effects right
i didn't have any jaundice or anything
else that would indicate an impaired
liver function
no like yellowing of the eye
i've never had my bilirubin levels out
of range um
so i think it's it just and your liver
enzymes are a little bit elevated
but when you train very very hard your
liver enzymes elevate also because these
enzymes are also found in skeletal
muscle you stress your body a little bit
more too
right so and then i would take a week
off from training and everything would
kind of fall back into baseline and then
i would
assume okay i'm good and then i did some
organ imaging
i guess a routine checkup and then i was
diagnosed with non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease but i think that happened over
maybe three or four years and because
you want to get bigger you eat more food
yeah well yeah that's like one of the
things that stresses your body and your
organs is
high high caloric you know consumption
that's why there's a lot of
um you know medical experts that are
that are talking more and more about
fasting and you know like giving your
you know giving like the road works a
little bit of a break so you take food
out of the equation right
you